hola
[Música]
bienvenidos a más humanos que nunca el
espacio en el que france24 repasa el
cambio de paradigmas que este año dejó
el deporte mundial soy el mar esa y para
revisar el papel de los atletas en este
cambio me acompaña rodrigo sedano más
alto más rápido más fuerte en búsqueda
de hazañas y récords el deporte de alto
rendimiento es un desafío permanente a
los límites humanos pero este año los
súper atletas han mostrado su lado más
humano
la regla 50 de la carta olímpica que les
prohibía hacer manifestaciones en el
contexto de los juegos olímpicos fue
modificada este 2021 vimos a los grandes
campeones usando la palestra competitiva
para involucrarse en causas como cambio
climático
diversidad derechos humanos lucha contra
el racismo pero también los vimos
padeciendo los problemas de cualquier
ser humano ansiedad depresión traumas y
mostrando ante el mundo su fragilidad
hace 53 años este gesto trajo graves
consecuencias a los tres atletas del
podio la carrera deportiva del
australiano peter norman terminó como
consecuencia de su solidaridad con los
estadounidenses tommy smith y john
carlos ellos dos fueron expulsados de la
villa y del equipo de su país 53 años
después ese mismo gesto es sinónimo de
una nueva hazaña los atletas han
conquistado su propia voz las primeras
manifestaciones en los últimos años
fueron objeto de amenazas hubo desde
patrocinantes descontentos hasta
advertencias del comité olímpico
estadounidense
eso cambió cuando la comisión de atletas
del comité olímpico internacional
propuso reinterpretar la regla a 50 para
en palabras de la propia comisión abogar
por cambios importantes para nosotros y
para el mundo el artículo original
rezaba no se permitirá ningún tipo de
manifestación o propaganda política
religiosa o racial en los sitios sedes u
otras áreas olímpicas pero en los
últimos años muchos atletas se
involucraron en causas como black lies
matters
o la defensa del medio ambiente el
silencio dejó de ser una opción para
atletas que sufrieron abusos como las
integrantes del equipo de gimnasia de
eeuu víctimas del médico la reina sar y
de la inacción de la federación y el
comité olímpico de su país la presión
sobre los comités olímpicos nacionales
se trasladó al internacional el texto
original de la regla no cambió pero la
comisión de atletas recomendó permitir
que los deportistas olímpicos mostraran
sus posturas sobre diversos temas en
entrevistas ruedas de prensa redes
sociales o durante su presentación ante
las competiciones desde el primer día de
competición en tokio 2020 el cambio
comenzó a verse los equipos femeninos de
fútbol de cinco países se arrodillaron
antes del pitido inicial para mostrar su
rechazo al racismo pero cuál es el valor
del mensaje de un atleta comprometido en
su momento el deporte tuvo el poder de
evitar una guerra civil en sudáfrica
nelson mandela reunificó a un país
profundamente dividido en torno a la
selección de rugby que ha participado en
el mundial
el capitán françois pinar fue uno en ese
proceso el atleta puede ser un potente
amplificador de todo tipo de causas un
simple abrazo en el podio durante los
juegos de beijing 2008 ayudó a des
escalar las tensiones entre rusia y
georgia por el control de osetia del sur
un futbolista marcus ransford logró un
cambio de política en el gobierno
británico para garantizar alimentación
en pandemia a niños de todo el país
incluso durante las vacaciones y en la
copa libertadores femenina un ataque
racista fue repelido con un gesto que se
ha vuelto universal
la movilización de jugadores del
circuito de tenis han mantenido vigente
la figura de pensar una ex campeona de
dobles de wimbledon que desapareció de
la vista pública después de denunciar
haber sido víctima de violación por
parte de un ex vice primer ministro
chino el pívot turco de los celtics enes
kánter ha prestado su voz a diversas
causas de defensa de los derechos
humanos otro jugador de la nba el
finlandés de los cavaliers laurie marcan
en motiva a sus seguidores a reducir la
huella de carbono en 2018 allyson felix
enfrentó a su antiguo sponsor por
desmejorar su contrato cuando ella
decidió tener un hijo
su lucha derivó en un cambio de
políticas en el patrocinio de las madres
atletas y sentó las bases para el
triunfo de varias de ellas en tokio 2020
pero hubo una causa más íntima que
movilizó este año a los atletas del
mundo no mios acá no asistió wimbledon y
simón bailes no compitió en todos los
eventos previstos en los juegos
olímpicos
su ausencia marcó una diferencia
histórica para los atletas del mundo
hasta ese momento el deporte solo había
estado frente a frente
y salud mental cuando era muy tarde o lo
había mirado como una situación aislada
cuando el mayor ganador de medallas
olímpicas en la historia michael phelps
reveló detalles de su lucha contra la
depresión
osaka y baile hablaron fuerte y claro y
el deporte comenzó a mirar a su lado más
oscuro una atleta venezolana que entreno
en las condiciones más precarias para
los juegos olímpicos usó la palestra de
tokio 2020 para compartir su calvario
personal y convertirse en una voz para
quienes han pasado por las sombras del
deporte después de lima
tuve pensamientos de astrada contra mi
vida no quería seguir y hoy me siento
feliz de haber superado esos momentos
tormentosos las personas que estuvieron
conmigo
soy
lo difícil que fue para mí y el cambio
que hice me quedo con eso paula pérez
compartió con france24 su proceso tal
vez muy similar al que otros atletas de
alto rendimiento han pasado en sus vidas
primero no sabe que está en ese proceso
simplemente siempre me sentía muy triste
como que siempre cuestionada la razón de
vivir siempre las apuro porque lo que
más me afectará para mí en las
madrugadas a nadal sobre todo en la
época de invierno
mejor en la bicicleta llorando y decía
pero porque algo de asesinar nadie me
obliga de las tres porque lo hago si si
al final bueno ya que unos juegos
olímpicos
extrañan mucho a mis papás por su era lo
que más extrañaba en ese momento en mi
caso en mi cama el cuarto este ese
ambiente que estaba en mi entorno
constantemente y después entre tanto
preguntarme eso también me cuestiona
mucho para ir e incluso para que estoy
vivían las noches también eran horribles
porque me entraba mucho crisis de llanto
siempre era una tristeza y un y no le
encontraba sentido a nada hasta que
bueno el detonante podría decir que lo
hizo los panamericanos ese fue como el
punto de quiebre máximo que desde ahí me
hundí marc pero ese fue mi fondo porque
me empecé a sentir bien ya no podía
hablar a decírmelo
como ciertas ganas de llorar pero es
porque me siento muy orgullosa de lo que
logré de los cambios que hice si está o
no lista no tampoco lo pensé simplemente
sentía las ganas de
comunicarle a la gente porque bueno si
bien también conecté mucho con las
personas por el tema migratorio que
muchos creo que toda la persona que mira
pasa por ese estado emocional y sabía
que había mucha gente que por lo que los
mensajes que me escribieron mucha gente
que está viendo mi éxito está viviendo
mi situación emocional pero en otra
faceta entonces yo dije bueno quizás a
través de de este alcance que tenía
puedo no ayudar a personas como darles
terapia algo que no esté especialista
pero si ciertos consejos que yo hice y
él y creo que es un tema que sí hay que
prestar leer la misma atención que
oficial del masajista del entrenamiento
del estado físico todo todas esas cosas
son parte de nuestro de nosotros mismos
para el reparar el resultado no competen
para tratar este tema conversamos con
maría milagros ezquerro ex directora del
servicio de psicología del deporte de la
universidad de la coruña y autora de
libros sobre el tema a ella le
preguntamos antes de que se dieran casos
como el de osaka o bailes los temas
clínicos no se incluyen en el abordaje
psicológico de un atleta de alto
rendimiento
ocurren dos cosas uno hay una gran
cantidad de psicólogos del deporte que
no tienen formación clínica por tanto no
pueden abordar otras cuestiones
ajenas a la competición de de
rendimiento
en segundo lugar los psicólogos que
tienen formación clínica trabajan con
deportistas por ética profesional no van
a divulgar nunca que están atendiendo un
trastorno clínico o un trastorno su
tiene por tanto queda oscurecida su
labor lo cual no quiere decir que no
exista sí que existe más que es que las
características de una determinada
modalidad deportivo predispongan luego
pueden hacer es precipitar o
desencadenar una predisposición que
tiene el deportista previamente
cualquier persona deportista formado
deportista voy a tener una cierta
predisposición a tener a uatre de
ansiedad o tener cuadros obsesivos oa
cualquier tipo de trastorno con mayor o
menor gravedad pero no siempre se
desencadena un deportista como persona
puede experimentar un trastorno químico
o un trastorno subclínico pero no
influye negativamente en el rendimiento
hay algunos deportistas que a pesar de
estar pasando a circunstancias duras
como es el fallecimiento de una persona
querida o una sucesión de lesiones son
capaces de rendir espléndidamente en el
ámbito deportivo porque se sobreponen a
esas circunstancias
los super humanos fueron en 2021 más
humanos que nunca frágiles comprometidos
cercados por la pandemia igual que el
resto de la humanidad decididos a
cambiar el mundo el año que pasó
cambiará para siempre la forma en que
vemos a los ídolos deportivos el mundo
ganón mensajeros necesarios y el deporte
conquistó su propia voz muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros en esta
especial de france 24 nos invitamos a
seguir con más información
[Música]